hundreds of hong kong police raided the
stan news office in the early hours of
wednesday morning using a warrant under
the much criticized national security
law to collect boxes of what were
described as journalistic materials
six people linked to the independent
media outlet were arrested under a
separate law on sedition from the
british colonial era
by wednesday afternoon stand news
announced it was closing after seven
years we are not they're talking to the
reporter we are not talking the
the media we just targeted national
security
law the offenses
among those arrested was well-known
singer and activist denise ho and former
politician margaret ung both former stan
news board members
police turned up at the home of stan
news deputy assignment editor ronson
chan officers telling him to stop
recording as they arrived chan who is
chairman of the hong kong journalists
association stood by the now disbanded
news organization
has been doing professional reporting
there's no doubt about it the whole
world sees it it doesn't matter what
charges have been made nothing can
change that fact the hong kong
journalists association said it was
deeply concerned by the arrests and
urged the government to respect the
media freedoms that are meant to be
safeguarded under the city's
mini-constitution the basic law
hong kong chief secretary john lee
shrugged off the criticism saying
journalism cannot be used as a tool
against national security they are
the evil elements
that
damage press freedom china's government
in beijing says the security law in hong
kong is necessary for stability
following political unrest and mass
pro-democracy protests
dozens have been arrested prosecuted and
jailed since china imposed the
legislation last year six months ago the
last remaining pro-democracy paper apple
daily was forced to shut down after its
assets were frozen and its founder jimmy
lai arrested
the closure of the apple daily left
stand news is one of the last
pro-democracy outlets in hong kong now
there are questions over whether smaller
online outlets can survive the crackdown
on media freedoms britt clenet al
jazeera hong kong